hello and welcome to this course on
reinforcement learning
my name is harvan husselt and i'm a
research scientist at deepmind in london
and every year we teach this course on
reinforcement training at ucl
this year it's a little bit different
because due to the pandemic situation
with covet 19
we are pre-recording the lectures so
instead of talking from a lecture hall
i'm now talking to you from my home
um the topic of course as mentioned is
reinforcement training i will explain
what that means what those words mean
reinforcement learning and
we'll go into
some depth in uh multiple lectures to
explain different concepts and different
algorithms that we can build
i'm not teaching this course by myself
some of the lectures will be taught by
diana bursa and some will be told by
matteo hessel
and today will be about introducing
reinforcement learning
there's also a really good book on this
topic by
rich sutton and andy bartow which i
highly recommend and this is also going
to be used basically background material
for this course
and if you go to the url that is shown
here on the slide you can access
a free
copy of that book
just a little bit of admin before we get
started for students taking this for
credit at ucl
there's a portal called moodle
and we'll be using that to communicate
with you so please check that for
updates and please use the forum thereon
for asking questions
if you do that then if we answer these
questions and other people can also
benefit from that interaction and
multiple people might have the same
question
or people might have a question but not
even realize that they have that
question so then it's very useful if you
ask it publicly on that forum
in terms of grading we will have
assignments
which will be graded this year there
will not be an exam
so now about this course specifically
what are we talking about
um the main question for this first
lecture especially is just the question
what is reinforcement learning and
i'll explain it a little bit and then
we'll go into a lot of depth into
different subtopics of this question
and in order to understand what
reinforcement is it's actually useful to
first ask the question what artificial
intelligence is and how these two are
related because turns out these are
closely related
and
to understand at least what i mean when
i say artificial intelligence i'm going
to pop up a level
and we're going to turn first to the
industrial revolution
so
this is a period in time that happened a
couple of hundred years ago or started a
couple hundred years ago and one could
argue this is all about automating
repeated physical solutions or manual
solutions if you will so think for
instance of a steam train or a steamboat
and how this replaced the manual labor
of pulling a cart by yourself or using
for instance animal labor horses
to draw those cards
now of course some of that still happens
we still have a manual layer but we
replaced a lot of that with machines and
this led to the machine age where we
started replacing more and more things
with machines and in addition to that
also coming up with new things that we
could solve with machines so even things
that we weren't doing before we could
now make machines that could do those
things for us
of course this led to huge productivity
increase worldwide
and it also fed into a new stage you
could argue comes after this
which you could call the digital
revolution
and one way to interpret this is to say
the digital revolution was all about
automating repeated mental solutions
so a classic example here would be a
calculator
we know how to add two numbers together
we know how to multiply two numbers
together and in fact we know that
precisely enough that we can write a
program and implement that on a machine
on a computer if you will
and then automate that process in such a
way that it's very fast and very precise
and therefore replace the slower mental
calculations that we had to do before
now this of course
also led to a lot of productivity
increase
but both of these phases they have
something in common which is that we
first had to come up with the solutions
now i'm going to argue that there's a
next thing that you can think of which
is already ongoing
and that would be
to allow machines to find solutions
themselves and this you could call the
domain of artificial intelligence
now this has huge potential upside
because if you are able to find machines
that can learn for themselves to find
solutions
then this takes away the responsibility
on us to find a solution in advance and
then to automate it
instead then all that we need to do is
specify a problem and a goal
and then have the machine figure out how
to solve this
as we'll see later this will often
involve interacting
you have to have some data to find the
solution
and this means that there's a process of
learning so here we already bump into
this term learning which i'll get into
much more in depth
in addition this requires you to
autonomously make decisions so i'm i'm
putting these
terms basically up front and center so
there's learning and autonomy and
decisions and these are all quite
central to this
generic problem of trying to find
solutions
of course we're not the first to talk
about artificial intelligence
this has been a topic of investigation
for many decades now and there's this
wonderful paper by alan turing from 1950
called computing machinery and
intelligence
and the very first sentence of that
paper reads i propose to consider the
questions can machines think
now
i by the way recommend you to read this
paper it's wonderfully written it's very
accessible and it has lots of really
interesting thoughts but there's one
paragraph that i want to highlight
specifically
and i'll read that to you now
so alan turing writes
in the process of trying to imitate an
adult human mind we are bound to think a
good deal about the process which has
brought it to the state that it is in
we may notice three components the
initial state of the mind say at birth
the education to which it has been
subjected and other experience not to be
described as education to which it has
been subjected
instead of trying to produce a program
to simulate the adult mind why not
rather try to produce one which
simulates the child's
if this were then subjected to an
appropriate course of education one
would obtain the adult brain
presumably the child brain is something
like a notebook as one buys it from the
stationers
rather little mechanism and lots of
blank sheets mechanism and writing are
from our point of view almost synonymous
our hope is that there is so little
mechanism in the child brain that
something like it can be easily
programmed
so what is aventurine talking about here
he's essentially talking about learning
he's essentially conjecturing that
trying to write the program which
constitutes an adult mind might be quite
complicated which makes sense because
we're subjected to a lot of experience
throughout our lives this means we learn
a lot of you can think of these as being
rules or
pattern matching that we learn how to do
skills that we acquire
and enumerating all of that describing
that all of that clearly enough and
cleanly enough that you have something
with the same capability as an adult
mind
he's conjecturing that that might
actually be quite tricky
and maybe it's easier to actually write
a program that can itself learn in the
same way maybe that we do or maybe in a
similar way or maybe in a slightly
different way
but it can learn by interacting with the
world
by
in in his words subjecting itself to
education
um
maybe to find similar solutions as the
adult mind has
and he's conjecturing that maybe this is
easier
now this is a really interesting thought
and it's really interesting to think
about this a little bit
so
maybe this is a good time for you also
to maybe pause the video and ponder this
a little bit whether you agree with this
conjecture that indeed maybe it might be
easier to write a program that can learn
than it is to write a program that has
the same capabilities as the program
that can learn will achieve over time
so what is an artificial intelligence
well one way to define it would be
that the
goal would be to to be able to learn to
make decisions to achieve goals this is
not the only possible definition of
artificial intelligence and other people
have proposed sometimes slightly
different versions or vastly different
versions i'm not going to argue that
this is the best definition of
artificial intelligence maybe there are
different types of artificial
intelligence that we could consider but
this is the one that is central to us so
we're going to basically ask this
question how could we build something
that is able to learn to make decisions
to achieve goals
and that is our central question
and note that the learning decisions and
goals are all very central concepts in
this and we'll get into a little bit
more detail what i mean with all of them
so this brings us to this question what
is reinforcement learning
and
this is related to this um
experience that alan turing was also
talking about because we know that
people and animals learn by interacting
with our environment
and this differs from certain other
types of learning and that's good to
appreciate first of all it's active
rather than passive and we'll get back
to that extensively in the next lecture
what this means is that you
are subjected to some data or experience
if you will
but the experience is not fully out of
your control the actions that you take
might influence the experience that you
get
in addition to that interactions might
be sequential so
future interactions might depend on
earlier ones if you do something this
might change the world in such a way
that later other things are possible or
impossible we are also goal directed we
don't just randomly meander we do things
with a purpose
and this this is also this is at large
but also at small scale i might have a
goal to pick up a glass for instance
that is a small thing perhaps but you
could think of this as being a directed
action where i pick up that glass and of
course this consists of many small
little micro actions of
me sending signals to my muscles to
actually execute that
also we can learn without examples of
optimal behavior and this one's
interesting it's good to think about
that a little bit and to appreciate what
i mean when i say with that because
obviously we are subjected to education
as engineering courses so we do get
examples of what we um
behavior that we want or behavior that
other people want us to do and we try to
follow those examples in many cases
but what i mean here is something a
little bit different i mean that when
you do pick up a cup
that maybe somebody showed you at some
point oh it's useful to pick up a cup um
or you could think of it that way maybe
that's not the greatest example of that
but somebody taught you how to write or
taught you how to do math
but nobody actually told you exactly how
to steer your muscles in such a way as
to move your arm to pick up a pen to
pick up a cup things like this
so clearly we still learn some sort of a
behavior there we learn to control our
muscles but not in a way that somebody
tells you exactly oh this is how you
should have moved your muscle and now
you just replicate so that is what i
mean when i say we learn without
examples nobody gives you exactly the
low level actions that are required to
execute
that thing that you want to execute
and
this actually
maybe constitutes most of the learning
that we do most of the learning that we
do is actually of that form where maybe
we do interpret something that we see in
some sense as an example but maybe
typically at a much higher level of
abstraction and in order to actually
fill in that example in order to execute
what we want to mimic this might still
require us to learn skills in a much
more
autonomous way without clear examples
so one way to think about this and i'll
go back to this is that you can think of
this as optimizing some reward signal we
want to achieve something and by
achieving it we feel in some sense
satisfaction or happiness and this is
what stares our behavior we notice that
some things are more pleasing than other
things
so this brings us to a very central uh
picture that i'm going to show multiple
times during this course which is the
interaction loop and one can perceives
this as being basically the setting that
we find ourselves in
so this is something to keep in mind
that we are basically considering an
agent interacting with an environment
and here i drew them separately but you
could also think of the agent as
basically being inside that environment
there's a huge world out there the agent
lives somewhere in that world now this
could be um quite concrete for instance
the agent could be a robot and the
environment could be the real world it
could also be much more abstract for
instance the environment could be some
abstract game or it could be a virtual
environment
it could be the internet and the agent
could be some program that tries to
interact with that environment instead
so it's quite a flexible framework
and we basically say that the agent then
executes actions and observes the
environment this is typically drawn in
such a way as i did here where the
actions go from the agent into the
environment and the observations go from
the environment into the agent but of
course you could also think of the
observation as being something that the
agent pulls in in fact the observation
typically depends on the agent because
the agent will have some sort of sent a
sensory
motor stream that is defined by its
interface for instance the agent could
have a camera and that defines which
observations it gets
so
the main purpose of this course is then
to go basically inside that agent and
figure out how we could build learning
algorithms that can help that agent
learn
to interact better and what does better
mean here well the
agent is going to try to optimize some
reward signal
this is how we're going to specify the
goal and the goal is not to optimize the
immediate reward so we're not just
interested in taking an action and then
forgetting about everything that might
happen after no we're actually
interested in optimizing the sum of
rewards into the future
i'll explain it a little bit more
clearly in a moment but it's good to
appreciate that there must be some goal
to this right if there's no goal
specified then it's unclear what we're
actually optimizing and it's unclear
what the agent will actually learn to do
so we need some way some mechanism to
specify that goal
many cases when people show versions of
this interaction loop when talking about
reinforcement learning they put these
rewards next to the observation and
that's one useful way to think about
this that you take an action and then
the environment gives you an observation
and a reward
but sometimes it's a bit more natural to
think of the reward as being internal to
the agent
so you could also think of the reward
signal as being some sort of a
preference function over these
observations or over sequences of
observations that the agent receives and
the agent just observes the world and
feels happier or less happy about what
it sees and then tries to optimize its
behavior in such a way that it achieves
more of these rewards
so this is why i didn't put the reward
in the figure because sometimes it's
easier to think of it as just coming
from the environment through the
external to the agent sometimes it's
easier to think of it as being in some
sense part of the agent but it should
still be there and it should be clearly
specified because otherwise it's unclear
what the goal of this whole system would
be
and
this reward function is quite central so
it's good to stop and think about why
this is a good way to specify a goal and
this is formulated in this reward
hypothesis that we see on the slide
which states that any goal can be
formalized as the outcome of maximizing
a cumulative reward
now i want to encourage you to think
about that and think about it critically
and try to see if you can maybe even
break it in some sense so breaking it
would mean coming up with a counter
example of a goal that you cannot
specify by maximizing the cumulative
reward
feel free to pause the video and think
about this for a bit
so i've not been able to come up with
examples myself
and maybe this is somewhat even
trivially
true in some sense
because you could think of a reward
signal that basically just checks
whether you've achieved that goal that
we want to specify and then whenever
you've achieved the goal the reward
signal becomes one and before that it's
zero
then optimizing this cumulative reward
would clearly correspond to maximizing
or achieving that goal
doesn't mean it's easy to specify that
sometimes it's hard to specify your goal
precisely or
sometimes it's hard to specify a reward
which is easy to optimize which is a
completely different problem but that's
not under
this reward hypothesis this just states
that there must exist a reward and
indeed sometimes there's many different
ways to specify the same goal for
instance instead of saying you get a
reward of plus one whenever you achieve
the goal and zero before that you could
also say let me give you a reward of
minus one in some sense a penalty on
every step before you've achieved the
goal and then zero rewards after you've
achieved it
then you could think of the agent as
maximizing this cumulative reward as in
some sense minimizing these penalties
which would also then maybe lead to the
behavior of achieving the goal as
quickly as possible because minimizing
the number of -1 rewards number of steps
until you've achieved the goal will then
become relevant
so we see that a goal could also include
not just
that it happens but also when it happens
if we specify it in this way so it's
quite a flexible framework
and
it seems to be a useful one that we can
also use to
create
create concrete algorithms that work
rather well
so some examples some concrete examples
of what reinforcement learning problems
could then exist
so here's a list including flying a
helicopter managing an investment
portfolio controlling a power station
making a robot walk or playing video or
board games
all of these examples were picked
because they have actually been used and
reinforcement has been applied to them
successfully
and for instance we could have a reward
function for the helicopter that is
related to air time or inverse distance
to some goal
or to pick for instance the video games
you could or board games you could think
of a reward function that just looks at
whether you win or not so think of the
game of chess for instance you could
have a reward function that gives you
plus one whenever you win minus one
whenever you lose
and if the goal isn't to learn via
interaction these are all reinforcement
learning problems
this is irrespective of which solution
you use and i put that on the slide
because sometimes people conflate the
current set of algorithms that we have
in reinforcement learning to solve these
type of problems with the field of
reinforcement learning but it's good to
separate that out and to appreciate that
there's a reinforcement building problem
and then there's a set of current
solutions that people have considered to
solve these problems
and
that set of solutions might be under a
lot of development they might change
over time
but it's first good to think about and
appreciate whether we agree with the
the goal with the problem statement
and if we agree with the problem
statement then we can think flexibly
about the solutions we don't have to be
dogmatic about that and we can think
about new solutions that achieve the
same goal
so it's good to separate that out and i
would argue that if you're doing any of
these problems where there is a reward
function errors or sequential
interaction then you're doing
reinforcement learning whether or not
you call your algorithm three and four
enforcement learning algorithms
so
in each of these
problems that i specified these
reinforcement training problems there
might actually be two distinct reasons
to learn
so the first one maybe obviously is to
find solutions
so going back to the example of the
helicopter for instance you might want
to find a
policy of behavior for this for this
helicopter so that it flies to a goal as
quickly as possible
but maybe in order to optimize its
cumulative reward it also sometimes has
to do some more complicated things such
as
first go somewhere else to refuel
because otherwise it won't even reach
the goal
but in the end you might have some
learning process and you might find a
solution two examples here to make that
concrete you could think of a program
that plays chess really well that might
be something you desire
or you might want a manufacturing robot
with a specific purpose
and then reinforcement could potentially
be used to solve these problems and then
to deploy that solution
now a subtly different but importantly
different thing that you might want is a
system that can adapt online
and the purpose for this would be to
deal with unforeseen circumstances
so to take the same two examples and to
contrast what we
how this is different in the chess
program for instance you might not want
a chess program that displays maybe the
most optimal form of tests that you can
find
but instead you might want to find a
program that learns to adapt to you now
why would you do that well for instance
you might want a program that doesn't
win too often because then maybe your
enjoyment is less so instead of
optimizing the number of times it wins
maybe it actually wants to optimize so
that the number of times it wins is
maybe like roughly half of the time or
something like that or maybe it wants to
optimize how often or how long you play
it because maybe that's a good proxy for
how much you enjoy playing it
similarly you can think of a robot that
can learn to navigate unknown terrains
maybe you can pre-train this
manufacturing robot from the first
example because you have a very good
simulator for the setting that it might
be in
but in other cases maybe you don't have
a very good simulator or maybe you do
have good simulators for different types
of the terrains that the robot might
encounter but you do not know yet
exactly what the terrain will look at
where it will be deployed and there
might be unknown unknowns there might be
things that you haven't foreseen
in those cases obviously it's quite
useful if you can continue to adapt if
you can continue to learn and we do that
as well we continue to learn throughout
our lifetimes
so that's a different purpose but
fortunately reinforcement learning can
provide algorithms for both those cases
it's still good to keep in mind that
these are actually different goals and
sometimes that becomes important
note that the second point about
adaptive
algorithms to be able to adapt online is
not just about generalizing it's not
about finding a solution similar to in
the first category but one solution that
is very general in some sense now it's
really about unknown unknowns it's
really about what if the environment
changes what if for instance you have a
robot and it gets deployed and at some
point there's wear and tear and you
haven't foreseen this there was no way
to know exactly what would happen
and
all of a sudden the robot has to deal
with this somehow then if it can't adapt
online then it's really hard to find a
solution that is generic enough general
enough that can deal with that
and in indeed there are other reasons
why it might be useful to learn online
because it might be easier to have a
smaller program that continues to
continue to track the world around it
than it is to try to find this one
humongous solution that can deal with
all of the unforeseen circumstances that
you could possibly come up with
so these are really different
different settings
okay so now we finally are ready
basically to answer this question what
is reinforcement learning and i'm going
to say that basically reinforcement
learning is the science and framework of
learning to make decisions from
interaction
so reinforcement learning is not a set
of algorithms also not a set of problem
problems sometimes in shorthand we say
reinforcement planning when referring to
the algorithms but maybe it's better to
say reinforcement learning problems or
reinforcement learning algorithms
especially if we want to specify those
two different parts of it and then
reinforcement learning itself could just
be the the science and the framework
around all of that
this has some interesting properties it
requires us to think about time and
consequences of actions and this is a
little bit different from many other
types of learning from for instance
other types of machine learning where
oftentimes you are given a data set and
for instance you want to find a
classifier or something of the form
and then
maybe there are no long-term
consequences you basically just
specify that your goal is to minimize
the errors that the system makes
now in reinforcement learning we would
argue that maybe
you want to consider the whole of the
system so maybe you don't just want to
consider the classifier but you also
want to consider the consequences of
classifying something wrong and that
might be taken into account if you
consider the whole framework
this makes it more challenging
and it also means we have to actively
gather experience because these actions
will change the data that we see
we might want to predict the future so
not just on one step thing so unlike a
classifier where you just get an input
and you're only interested in like the
input for that or the output for that
specific input we might actually want to
consider
future steps further into the future
which is an interesting and tricky
subject
and in addition we this is a more
typical thing that happens in machine
learning we have to deal with
uncertainty somehow
now the benefit of this is that there's
huge potential scope but you might have
also realized by that this is also very
complicated
or difficult question in general how to
solve this very generic problem
but the upside is huge if we are able to
find good generic algorithms that can
deal with this very generic setting then
maybe we can apply this to many
different problems successfully
and indeed one way to think about
reinforcement planning is that it's a
formalization of the ai problem as i
defined it earlier
so
it's good to appreciate the the basic
the ambition here that reinforcement
building is quite an ambitious vicious
endeavor that doesn't mean that of
course it sits on an island and in fact
we will see
uh during this course that current day
reinforcement learning is very
synergetic with uh
with deep learning which is all about
training deep neural networks
and
indeed
this is also very it seems very very uh
suitable component for a full ai problem
so the reinforcement learning
description is just about formalizing
the problem that doesn't mean that we
don't need solutions from all sorts of
subparts of machinery
okay now i'm going to show you an
example
what we see here is an atari game this
is an old video game from the 1980s
called beam rider
and the agent that is playing this game
has learned to play it by itself
its observations were the pixels as you
also see them on the screen
here's a different atari game with
different pixels
and in each of these cases the actions
that the agents would take are the motor
controls which are basically just the
joystick inputs for the atari
games which means the agent could press
up down left right or diagonally and it
will press a fire button
and then the agent just had to deal with
that in input output stream so it just
gets these observations these pixels
from the screen and it outputs these uh
joystick controls and we see that they
did relatively well learning to play
each of these different games even
though they're quite different so here's
a racing game enduro
and it's good to appreciate that the
agent is not even told what it's
controlling right it just gets these
pixels so it's not told oh there's this
thing at the bottom here which is kind
of meant to be a racing car and your
goal is to pass these other cars now
instead you just get these pixels you
get your motor controls and you get a
reward signal
now in these games the reward signal was
defined as the difference in score on
every time step
on a lot of time steps this difference
in score is zero that's fine but on
other time steps it will be positive and
the agent tries to maximize the
summation of that over time so it wants
to take actions that will lead it to
good rewards later on
now the most important thing to take
away from this is that we have used a
learning system to find these solutions
but we didn't need to know anything
about these games ourselves like there
was nothing put into the agent in terms
of strategy or even in terms of prior
knowledge on what you're controlling on
the screen
so the agent when it started playing
space invaders did not know that it was
going to control this thing at the
bottom which is shooting
or that it was controlling one of these
boxes in this example
and that is the benefit of having a
generic learning algorithm in this case
this algorithm is called dq n and we'll
discuss it later in the course as well
okay so now i'll go back to the
slides
so now i've given you a couple of
examples i've shown you these atari
games
and now is a good time to start
formalizing things a little bit more
completely so that we know a little bit
more what's happening
and in future lectures of course we will
make this much more
clear and rigorous and for now we're
going to give you kind of like a high
level overview of what happens here what
is this reinforcement learning problem
what's inside that agent how could this
work
so we're going to go back to this
interaction loop
and
we're going to introduce a little bit of
notation where we basically say that
every time step t we receive some
observation ot and some reward rt
as i mentioned the reward could also be
thought of as being inside the agent
maybe it's some function of the
observations or you could think of this
as coming with the observations from the
environment and then the agent executes
some action so the action can be based
on this observation ot in terms of our
sequence of interactions
and then the environment receives that
action and emits a new observation or we
could think of the agent as pulling in a
new observation and a next reward
note that we increment the time step
after taking the action
so we say that the action is emitted at
time step t and then the next
observation is
received at time set t plus one that's
just convention this is where we
increment the time index
you can actually extend reinforcement
learning to continuous time as well
rather than having these discrete time
steps
but we won't cover that in this course
the extensions are in some sense
not too difficult
so it's good to have that in mind
but there are some subtleties that one
would have to consider
so the reward here is a scalar feedback
signal it's just a number it can be
positive it can be negative a negative
reward you could call a penalty but we
just call that a negative reward just to
have this one word that refers to the
feedback signal
and just to recall i put the reward
hypothesis on the slide again where we
state that any goal can be formalized as
the outcome of maximizing a cumulative
reward
this
this instantaneous reward that indicates
how well the agent is doing at that time
step t
and this helps define the goal of the
agent
and the cumulative reward is and the
accumulation or the sum of these rewards
over time
it's useful to
also devote a letter to that which we'll
call g
so roughly speaking you can think of g
as kind of specifying the goal but we'll
use the term return to refer to this
so the return
is just shorthand for the cumulative
reward or the sum of rewards into the
future
note that the return is only about the
future right so this is at some time set
t so this is useful to determine which
action to take because your actions
cannot influence the past they can only
influence the future so when we define
the return the return is defined as all
of the future rewards summoned together
but the past rewards are in the past and
we can't change them anymore
then we can't maybe always hope to
optimize the return itself so instead
we're going to define the expected
return which we'll call a value
so the value at time s
would simply be the expectation of the
return
so that's the sum of the rewards going
into the future conditioned on the fact
that you're in that state s
i haven't defined what a state is yet
but for simplicity you could now think
of this as just being your observation
but i'll talk more about that in a
moment
so this value does depend on the actions
the agent takes and i will also make
that a little bit more clear in the
notation later on so it's good to know
that the expectation depends on the
dynamics of the world but also the
policy that the agent is following and
then the goal is to maximize the values
we want to pick actions such that this
value becomes large
so one way to think about that is that
rewards and values together define the
utility of states and actions
and there's no supervised feedback so
we're not saying this action is correct
that action is wrong instead we're
saying this sequence of actions has this
value that sequence of actions has that
value
and then maybe pick the one that has the
highest value
conveniently this and this is used in
many algorithms the rewards sorry the
returns and the values can be defined
recursively so the return at time sub t
can be thought of as simply the first
reward plus the return from that time
step t plus one
similarly the value can be defined
recursively so the value at some time
sorry the value at some state s
is the expected first reward you get
after being in that state and then the
value of the state you expect to be in
after being in that state
so the goal is maximizing value by
taking actions
and actions might have long-term
consequences so this is captured in this
value function because the value is
defined as the expected return where the
return sums the rewards into the future
and one way to think about this is that
actual rewards associated with certain
actions can be delayed
what i mean with that is you might pick
an action that might have consequences
later on
that are important to keep in mind but
that do not show up immediately in the
reward that you get immediately after
taking that action
this also means that sometimes it's
better to sacrifice immediate reward to
gain more long-term reward and i'll talk
more about that in the next lecture
so some examples of this might be one
that i mentioned before today
refuting a helicopter might be an
important action to take even if it
takes you slightly farther away from
where you want to go so this could be
formalized in such a way that the
rewards for that are low or even
negative for the act of refuting but the
sum of rewards over time might be higher
because eventually you get closer to
your goal than if you wouldn't refuel or
to pick the last example learning a new
skill might be something that is costly
and time consuming at first might not be
hugely enjoyable but maybe in the long
term it will yield you more benefits and
therefore you learn this new skill to
maximize your value rather than the
instantaneous reward
for instance maybe that's why you're
following this course
just in terms of terminology we call a
mapping from states to actions a policy
this is just shorthand in some sense for
an action selection policy
it's also possible to define
values on not just states but on actions
so these are typically denoted with the
letter q for historical reasons so we
have the letter v to denote the value
function of states and we have the
letter q to denote the value function of
states and actions and this is simply
defined as the expected return condition
on being in that state and then taking
that action a
so instead of considering some sort of a
policy which immediately could pick a
different action in state s we're saying
no no we're in state s and we're
considering taking this first action a
now this total expectation will then of
course still depend on the future
actions that you take so this still
depends on some policy that we have to
define for the future actions but we're
just pinning down the first action and
conditioning the expectation on that
we'll talk much more in depth about this
in
lectures three four five and six
so now we can basically summarize the
course concepts before we continue
so we said that the reinforcement
planning formalism includes an
environment which basically defines the
dynamics of the problem
it includes a reward signal which
specifies the goal
and sometimes this is taken to be part
of the environment but it's good to
basically list it separately
and then it contains an agent
now this agent might contain different
parts and most of this course will
essentially be about what's in the agent
what should be in the agent how could we
build learning algorithms that work well
and some of the parts are listed here so
the agent will contain some agent state
this is just the internal state of the
agent it will contain some policy
and it could contain a value function
estimate so a prediction of the value or
a model which might be a prediction of
the dynamics of the world i put
questions mark marks there because these
are in some sense more optional than the
first two the agent must have some
internal state this could be a very
simplistic state it could be a null
state or your agency could simply be the
immediate observation that you've
received right now but it could be a
more complicated state and it must have
some policy it must select actions in
some way
again this policy could be particularly
simple it could be a random policy that
just selects actions
completely uniformly at random but there
must be some policy
the value function and the model are
more optional in the sense that they're
not essential parts but they are very
common parts and i will discuss them a
little bit in the remainder of this
lecture
so now it's time to go into the agent
and we'll start with the alien state
so this is one way to depict the
internals of the agent so now we're
inside the agent and in this schematic
here on the right hand side time
increments as we go to the right
and so we see inside the agent from the
view inside the agent on every time set
there's an observation that comes in
and then there's some internal state of
the agent and from the state of the age
the agent might make predictions
and it should define some policy somehow
and then the action gets selected by
this policy so i could have basically
drawn another arrow going from the
policy into the action which would then
go back into the environment
but we're focusing here on that state
component and state here basically
refers to everything that the agent
takes along with it from one time to the
next
so if there are things that are not
taking along for instance the policy at
the instantaneous policy at the time set
might not be
taken along the predictions might not be
taken along or they could be in that
case they could just be part of the
state
but there might be other things in the
state as well there might be some memory
in the state there might be a learned
components in the states everything that
you take along with you from one time to
the next we could call the agent state
we can also talk about the environment
states which is the uh
the other side of that coin
um in many cases the environment will
have some really complicated internal
states for instance in uh the example
where the agent is a robot and the
environment is the real world then the
state of the environment is basically
just the state of all of the physical
quantities of the world all of the atoms
all of the quantum mechanics of the
world that's the environment state
of course in many smaller examples if
it's a virtual environment it could be
much smaller but it could still be quite
complicated this also means it's usually
invisible to the agent it's very really
really large and it's not part of the
observation stream per se
even if it would be visible it might
contain lots of irrelevant information
and it might just be simply too large to
process but actually the first one is
more interesting it's usually just
invisible to the agent we can only see a
sub-slice of it we can see a small part
of it via our observation stream
an important concept to keep in mind
then is that we can also formulate the
whole interaction sequence into
something that we could call the history
of the agent
and this is simply everything that the
agent could have observed so far so that
includes the observation from the
environment but also the actions that
the agent took and the rewards that it
received so this is really just taking
that interface and storing everything
that happens on the interface level and
we could call that the history of the
agent
so for instance it could be the full
sensory motor stream of the robo
now we can say that the history is the
only thing that can be used to construct
the aging stage in some sense apart from
whatever prior knowledge you put in all
the way at the beginning but let's just
set that aside for a moment and
everything else must be a function of
your history there's nothing else
essentially the agent has no additional
information
apart from its sensory motor stream so
that's that's what you should be using
to construct your agency
then a special case
is when the
agent can see the full environment state
so that the observation is the full
environment state and this is called
full observability i mentioned before
already this is a very special case this
is not the common case at all but it's a
useful one and sometimes it's used for
instance in theoretical statements just
because it's easier to reason about in
some cases
and in that case the agent state can
just be the observation right we don't
need to worry about this whole
interaction stream we can just observe
whatever the environment state is
and then this should be sufficient in
order to basically tell where you are
you don't need additional memory you
don't need anything else you just need
the environment state as your state
now in addition to that
there could be the learnable parts of
the agent right the agent might have
some parameters that it's learning and
you could also consider that to be part
of the agent state
in this case i'm actually not
considering that to be part of the
agency that's something that we also
have that's also part of the asians but
let's just set that aside and call that
the
the agent's mind is essentially separate
from its state in this sense
so in the fully observable case you can
just look at your observation you could
say oh that tells me everything i need
to know about the environment so i don't
need to log any of the previous
interactions
and this leads us to an important
concept in reinforcement training which
is the markov property
and this has been used to formulate
essentially the reinforcement problem
and also precursors to this
and importantly a markov decision
process is essentially a very useful
mathematical framework that allows us to
reason about algorithms that can be used
to solve these decision problems
the mark property itself states
that a process is markovian or a state
is markovian for this process if the
probability of a reward and a subsequent
state
doesn't change if we add more history
that's what the equation on the slide
means
so we can see the probability of a
reward and a state
you could you should interpret this as
the probability of those occurring on
times of t plus one
and we say that the the probability of
this happening condition on state st is
equal to conditions on the full history
up to the time set
that means if this is true that the
state contains
excuse me that the state contains all
the means you need to know
so we don't need to store anything else
from the history
doesn't mean that the state contains
everything
it just means that adding more history
doesn't help for instance if your
observations are particularly
uninformative
then adding more uninformative
observations might not help so that
might lead to a markovian state but it
doesn't mean that you can observe the
full environment state
however if you can observe the full
environment states then you're also
markovian
so once the state is known the history
might be thrown away if you have this
market property and of course this
sounds uh very useful because the state
itself might be a lot smaller than the
full history
so as an example the full agent and
environment state
is markov but it might be really really
large because as i mentioned the
environment state might be humongous it
might be the real world
and also the full history is markov
which you can kind of clearly read from
this equation because if you put
ht on the left hand side where it says
st then obviously this is true
but the problem with that is that that
state keeps growing so if we want to use
the full history as our agent states
then the
amount of memory that we're using inside
the agent's head keeps growing linearly
over time and sometimes that also
becomes too too large or actually
oftentimes it also becomes too large
so typically the agent said is some
compression of the history
whether it instead of the markov
property is actually
maybe not even the most important
question but it's an interesting thing
to keep in mind
so
note here that we use st deno to denote
the agent states not the environment
states
and we'll use that convention basically
throughout where sometimes as a special
case
these are these will be the same because
the environment state might be fully
observable
but in general we will not assume that
and then whenever you say states this is
basically the state and part on the side
of the agent and that's specified
differently
now i said that full observable cases
are very rare so that we should talk
about the uh the complement of that
which is the partial observable case so
in this case the observations are not
assumed to be markovian and i'll give
you an example or a couple of examples
so for instance a robot with a camera
which is not tallest absolute location
would not have markovian observations
because at some point it might be
staring at a wall
and it might not be able to tell where
it is it might not be able to tell
what's behind it or behind the wall
it can maybe just see the wall and then
this observation will not be markovian
because the probability of something
happening might depend on things that it
has seen before
but it doesn't see right now it may have
just turned around and there might be
information about what's behind it which
should influence the probability of what
happens next
but it can't see this from its
observations per se
similarly
a poker playing agent only observes
public cards and its own cards it
doesn't observe the cards from the other
players but obviously these are
important for its future rewards so part
of the environment state is then hidden
to the agent
so now using the observation essay would
not be markovian that doesn't mean it's
necessarily a bad idea but it means it
can be a bad idea because you're
ignoring some information that might be
contained in your past observations
this is then called a partial observable
markov decision process or pomdp for
short
and it's basically just an extension of
the market decision processes which
we'll define more rigorously in future
lectures
and it's good to keep in mind that this
is basically the common case
note that the environment state itself
could still be mark off it's just that
the agent can't see it and therefore
can't know it
in addition we might still be able to
construct a markov agent state
the example i gave in the previous slide
is you could always take your full
history and that would be markovian the
problem with that is just it's too large
but maybe there are smaller asian states
we can construct which still hold enough
information to be markovian
so the agent states
is
an important concept and
it must depend on this information that
you've seen before right this must
depend on this interaction stream
and the agent actions then depend on the
state
and it's some function of history so the
examples that i gave were like the
states could be the observation could be
your full history but more generally you
can also write this on recursively
where the state at your next time set t
plus one
is some function of your previous state
the action that you take that you've
taken the reward you've seen and the
observation that you see so we're taking
one step in this interaction loop and
we're basically saying we're going to
update the state
to
[Music]
be aware of this new time step
clearly if we're concatenating the
action reward and observation then st 1
could just be your full history if st is
your full history up to time step t
so
the full history is contained within
this formulation also quite clearly the
special case of just looking at the
observations contains formulation and
this is a more flexible way to think
about it
and then u is the state update function
now as i mentioned it's often useful um
to consider the agent's say to be much
much smaller than the environment set
and in addition you also typically
wanted to be much smaller than the full
history so we want this agent update
function
to give us some compression of the full
history
maybe recursively and maybe the state
actually stays the same size right so st
could be of a certain size we see new
action reward and observation and we
condense all of the information together
into something that is the same size as
st
and here's an example just to make that
a little bit more concrete all of that
so let's consider a maze and let's say
that the full state of the environment
in a maze is this layout
and in addition it's where you are in
the maze
and that would define the full
environment state
but let's say that the agent can't
observe all of that it can't observe its
location in the maze and instead maybe
you can only see this little three by
three around itself so in this case the
agent would be in the center of this
three by three uh block
and what it can see is exactly the
pixels around it the the cells around it
so it can see for instance that above it
it's empty
to the left and the right there's a wall
in black below it it's empty so it could
walk up it could walk down and also it
can look slightly around the corner
where i can see that if it goes up and
then right there's also an empty spot
but if it goes up and left it would bump
into a wall
and that's all that it can see
now this observation is
not markovian because if we look at a
different location
these observations are actually
indistinguishable
so if we would just use the observation
in this case then the agent won't be
able to tell where it is
and we can also talk about why that
might be problematic
so let's say that the agent starts in
the top right corner
and let's say that the goal for the
agent is to go to the top left corner
then if you consider the shortest path
in the state that we see the observation
that we see in the top right here the
optimal action would be the step down
because that's in the direction of the
goal because we have to go via the
bottom of this maze in order to reach
the top left corner
however if you then look at the left
observation in that observation the
optimal action would be to go up
but if the agent can't distinguish
between these two if it would be using
the observation as its full agent state
and its action selection policy must
depend on only that observation
then it's unclear what it should be
doing
in the top right it should be going down
in the left should be going up but
there's no single policy single function
of this observation that will do the
right thing in both cases
this is why it can be problematic to not
have a markovian state observation
so now
i actually actually want you to think
about for a second so feel free to pause
the video here
and think about how you might be able to
construct a markov in asian state for
this specific problem and maybe for any
reward sequence so not just for the one
that goes from the top right to the top
left but maybe that one that works for
any reward signal
so feel free to pause the video and then
i'll talk about this a little bit more
so one thing that you may have come up
with is well maybe we can use that thing
that you said where you can use the full
history yes the full history would be
markovian would be would be rather large
so i think many of you will have kind of
discounted that as being not the most
pleasant or feasible solution
so maybe we could do something that's a
little bit
in that direction but not quite the same
so let's say we consider storing not
just the observation that we see right
now but also the previous observation
would that work
well it kind of depends actually it
depends on the policy
and it depends whether the state
transitions here in the real world are
are completely deterministic so if you
go down you really go down or whether
there are some noise in there where
sometimes when you press down you
actually go up
because note that if you look at both of
these observations that are highlighted
right now if you step down one step the
observation is still the same
so if you would come from this situation
below where we currently are and you
would just concatenate these two
observations that would not be
sufficient to be able to tell where you
are so just concatenating two
observations is not necessarily
markovian in this environment
however
it can be sufficient if your policy
never does this so if we stepped on the
right hand side in the right top corner
right first we step left and then we
step down this brothers to where we
currently are
if we would have stored the fact that we
just stepped down and then we see this
then we know that we are where we are
because then the previous observation is
sufficient and then we step down again
and if the policy never does that same
action in the left state
then the ordering of the observations is
enough to distinguish the left from the
from the top right
but in general for any policy for
instance for a uniformly random policy
just concatenating two observations is
not sufficient in order to get a
markovian state in this case
okay
so in general what i'm doing there is
basically trying to construct a suitable
state representation to deal with the
partial observability in the maze
and as examples i mentioned using just
the observation might be enough using
the full history might be too large but
generic you can think of some update
function and then the question is how do
we pick that update function and that's
actually what we were doing just now
like we were trying to hand pick a
function u
that updates
the state in such a way to take into
account the stream of observations the
example that i gave where i just
concatenate two observations
would be where you just keep track of
this buffer and whenever you see a new
observation it basically replaces the
oldest observation with a new one
with a newer one and then adds the
newest one on top so you have
like a two observation buffer in that
case
excuse me
so this is a generic update you can you
can do other
other things there as well of course
but it's good to to note that
constructing a full markov unit you say
it might not be feasible like your
observation might be really complicated
and it might be really hard to construct
a full markovian agency and so instead
instead of trying to always shoot for
complete markovianness maybe that's not
necessary maybe it's more important that
we allow good policies and good value
predictions and sometimes that's easier
sometimes going for optimal is really
really hard but going for very good is
substantially easier and that's
something more generally that we'll keep
in mind when we want to deal with messy
big real world problems where optimality
might be out of reach
okay
now we're going to continue our journey
inside the agent and we're going to go
to the next bits which are the policy
the value function in the model starting
with the policy
so we covered the agencies now we're
going into policy and then immediately
into the value function and the model
and the policy is simply something that
defines the agent behavior it's not a
very complicated construct it's a
mapping from agent say to actions and
for instance we can write this like this
for a deterministic policy it could be
considered simply a function that takes
a state as input and outputs an action
now actually it will be more common and
uh often more useful to think of
stochastic policies where instead
pi means the probability of an action
given a state
pi is just conventional notation for
policies we often use pi to denote a
policy and the stochastic policies in
some some more general case so typically
we consider this a probability
distribution of actions
and that's basically it in terms of
policies of course we're going to say a
lot more about how to optimize these
policies how to represent them how to
optimize them and so on but in terms of
definitions all that you need to
remember is that pi denotes the
probability of an action given a state
and then we can move on to value
functions and value estimates
and i'm going to
what i have here on the slide is a
version of the value function as i
defined it earlier and i want to mention
a couple of things about this first of
all it's good to appreciate that this is
the definition of the value later we'll
talk about how to approximate that this
is just defining it
and i've extended it in two different
ways from the previous definition that i
had
first i made it very explicit now that
the value function depends on the policy
and the way to reason about this if i
have this conditioning on pi
means that i
uh i could write this long form to say
that every action at subsequent time
steps is selected according to this
policy pi
so note that we're not conditioning on a
sequence of actions
nowhere conditioning on a function that
is allowed to look at the states that we
encounter and then pick an action which
is slightly different
the other thing that we've done now on
this slide introduce a discount factor
this is a somewhat orthogonal thing but
i thought i should include it here so
that we have the generic form of a value
function which conditions on the policy
and includes potentially this discount
factor which is a very common construct
in reinforcement learning
and one way to think about that is that
the discount factor helps determine the
goal in addition to the reward function
for instance if you consider a reward
function to be plus one on every time
step
um
then it could be
infinitely large
alternatively if you think of a maze
where the reward is zero on every time
set until you reach the goal
then the value function for a uniformly
random policy would be
sorry if it's zero every time's at one
when you reach the goal then any policy
that eventually reaches goals gets a
value of one so then we can't
distinguish between getting there
quickly
so sometimes discount factors are used
to define goals in the sense oh maybe
it's better to look at the near-term
rewards a little bit more unless it's a
long-term reward so this allows us to
trade off the importance of immediate
versus long-term rewards
so to look at the extremes to make it a
bit more concrete you can consider a
discount factor of zero
if you plug that into the definition of
the value as it's
written on the slide there you see that
then the value function just becomes the
immediate reward all of the other
rewards are cancelled out because
they're multiplied with the zero
discount
so that means if your discount factor is
small or in a special case if it's zero
then you only care about the near term
future
if you don't want to optimize your
policy then the policy would also be a
myopic policy a short-sighted policy
which only cares about immediate reward
conversely the other extreme would be
when the discount factor is one this is
sometimes called the undiscounted case
because then the discounts basically
disappear from the value definition we
get the definition that we had before
where all rewards are equally important
not just the first one but the second
one also is equally important the first
one and that also means that you no
longer care in which order you receive
these rewards
and sometimes it's useful to have a
discount factor that is in between these
two extremes in order to define the
problem that you actually want to be
solving
now as i mentioned the value depends on
the policy and then ultimately we want
to optimize these so we want to be able
to reason about how can we pick
different policies
and we can now do that because the value
function cannot be used to evaluate the
desirability of states and also we can
compare different policies on the same
state we can say one value might have a
different sorry one policy might have a
higher value than a different policy and
then we can maybe talk about the
desirability of different policies
and ultimately we can also then use this
to select between actions so we could do
so no here we've defined the value
function as a function of a policy
but then if we have a value function or
estimated value function we can then
maybe use that to determine a new policy
so this will be talked about in a lot
more depth in future lectures but you
can think of this as kind of being
an incremental learning system where you
first estimate the value of a policy and
then you improve your policy by picking
better policies according to these
values and that's indeed a relevant
algorithm idea that we'll get back back
to later
as i mentioned before the value
functions and returns have recursive
forms so the return now has its discount
factor in the more general case
and the value function is also recursive
where again as i mentioned before the
value of a state can be defined as the
expected value of the immediate reward
plus now the discounted value at the
future state for that same policy
and here the notation a
tilde pi just means that a is sampled
according to the probability
distribution pi
and we'll just use that same notation
even if the probability distribution is
just deterministic for simplicity
this is called a bellman equation it was
first described by richard bellman in
the 1950s and it's useful because you
can turn it into algorithms
so these equations are heavily exploited
and a similar equation can be written
down
for the optimal value which is really
interesting
so note that the equation above this is
conditioned on some policies so we have
some policy and we can then determine
its value turns out we can also write
down an equation for the optimal
value that you can have so there is no
higher value that you can get in this
setting
and this turned out to adhere to this
recursion that is written on the slide
where v star the optimal value of state
s
is equal to the maximization over
actions of the expected reward plus
discounted next value conditioned on
that state in action
importantly this does not depend on any
policy it just depends on the state
and this recursion is useful
it defines recursively the um the
optimal value because know that the v
star is on the left hand side and the
right hand side but we can use this to
construct algorithms that can then learn
to approximate v-star
in the future
in future lectures we will heavily
exploit these equations and we'll use
them to create concrete algorithms
and in particular of course we often
need to approximately so the previous
slide just defines the value of a
certain policy and it defines the
optimal value doesn't tell you how to
get them and in practice you can't
actually get them exactly and we'll have
to approximate them somehow and we will
discuss several algorithms to learn easy
efficiently
and the goal of this would be that if
you have an accurate value function then
we can behave optimally i mean if we
have a fully accurate value function
because then you can just look at the
value function we could define a similar
equation that we had on the previous
slide for state action values rather
than just for state values
and then the optimal policy could just
be picking the optimal action according
to those values so if we have a fully
accurate value function we can use that
to construct an optimal policy this is
why these value functions are important
but if we have a suitable approximation
which might not be optimal might be we
might not be perfect it might still be
possible to behave very well even in
interactively large domains
and this is kind of the promise for
these approximations that we don't need
to find the precise optimal value in
many cases it might be good enough to
get close and then the resulting
policies might also be performed very
well
okay so the final component inside the
agent will be a potential model this is
an optional component similar to how the
value functions are optional although
they are very common
and a model here refers to a dynamics
model of the environment the term is
sometimes used more generally for other
things as well in uh artificial
intelligence or machine learning but in
reinforcement we typically when we say
we have a model we typically mean a
model of the world in some sense so that
means the model predicts what the
environment will do next for instance we
could have a model
p which predicts the next state
where maybe if you give it inputs as
inputs a state an action and a next
state the output of this thing is an
approximation to the actual probability
of seeing that next state after
observing this previous state and action
so again for simplicity might be good to
keep in mind a specific agent states
where for instance these agencies could
be your observation
then this would be the probability of
the next observation given the previous
observation and the previous action
and we could try to model that we could
try to approximate this
and then in addition we could also
approximate the reward function which
could be for instance conditioned on
state and action where this would just
be the expected reward given that you
are in that state and taking that action
a model doesn't immediately give us a
good policy like for value functions we
can actually just kind of read off a
policy if we have state action value
functions we can pick actions according
to these values for a model we don't
immediately have that we would still
need to conduct some sort of a planning
mechanism we'll talk about specific
algorithms that can be used in addition
to like uh sorry on top of a model in
order to extract a policy but it's good
to keep that in mind in general that the
model would still require additional
computation in order to extract a good
policy
in addition to the expectation above for
instance for the reward we consider the
expected reward
we could also consider a stochastic
model or
an expectation model for the state so
the state's
model here in particular
this would be an example of a
distribution model where we try to
actually
grasp the full distribution of the next
state given the current state in action
you could also instead try to
approximate the expected next state or
you could try to find a model that just
outputs a plausible next state
or maybe randomly gives you one of the
states that could happen these are all
choices design choices and it's not 100
clear in general yet what the best
choices are
and now i'll go through an example to
talk about all of these agent components
a little bit
it's just a very simple example we'll
see much more extensive examples in data
lectures
and in particular we're going to
consider this maze
so we'll start at the left and the goal
is at the right and we define a certain
reward function which gives you a minus
one per time step
that means that the optimal thing to do
is to go to the goal as quickly as
possible because then you'll have the
lowest number of minus ones
then the actions will be up down left
and right or north east south and west
if you prefer
and the agent location is the state
let's say that this is fully observable
so you can basically just tell where you
are maybe you could think of this as x y
coordinates which are easily
easily shown to be markovian in this
setting
so here's an example which shows a
policy
and in fact it shows the optimal policy
so in every state we see an arrow this
arrow depicts which action to take so
for instance in the left most states the
arrow points right
so we say that in the leftmost state the
policy now will take the action right
this policy is a deterministic policy
that indeed gives us the shortest
path to the goal and it will be an
optimal policy you could also consider a
stochastic policy which might select
multiple actions with non-zero
probability
here is the value of that policy on the
previous slide which happens to also be
the optimal value function which as you
can see increments every time you step
away from the goal and this is because
the value function is defined as the
expected
sum of rewards until uh
into in into the indefinite future but
if the episode ends at the goal then the
rewards stop there
so if you're one step away from the goal
the value will just be minus one for
that optimal policy if your two steps
away it will be -2 and so on
this is a model and specifically this is
an inaccurate model because note that
all of a sudden a part of the maze went
missing
so in this case the numbers inside the
squares are the rewards so these are
molds as just oh we've learned the
reward is basically minus one everywhere
maybe this is very quick and easy to
learn and the dynamics model was learned
by simply interacting with the
environments but turns out maybe we
haven't actually gone to that it's
that portion there in the left corner
left bottom corner and therefore the
model is inaccurate and wrong there if
you then would use this model's plan it
would still come up with the optimal
solution for the other states that this
can see but it might not have any
solutions for the states it hasn't seen
it's just an example of course it's
unrealistic to have an accurate value
function but an inaccurate model in uh
in this way specifically
but it's just an example to say oh yeah
your model doesn't have to be perfect if
you learn it it could be imperfect the
same of course holds for the policy and
value function these could also be
imperfect
okay now finally before we reach the end
of this lecture i'm going to talk about
a different
some different agent categories
and in particular this is basically a
categorization it's good to have this
terminology in mind which refers to
which part of the agent are used or not
used
and a value-based agent is a very common
uh
version of an agent and in this agent
we'll learn a value function but there's
not explicitly a policy separately
instead the policy is based on the value
function
this agent that i showed earlier that
was playing atari games is actually of
this form where this agent learns state
action value functions and then picks
the picks the highest rated action in
every state with a high probability
conversely you can think of a
policy-based agent which has an explicit
notion of a policy but doesn't have a
value function i haven't yet told you
any algorithms how you could learn such
a policy if you're not learning values
but we'll actually see an example of
that in the next lecture
and then there's the terminology actor
critic the term actor critic refers to
an agent which both has an explicit
representation of a policy
and an explicit representation of a
value function these are called actor
critics because the actor refers to the
policy part there's some part of the
agent that acts and the value function
is then typically used to update that
policy in some way so this is an
interpreted as a critic that critiques
the actions that the policies takes and
helps it select better policies over
time
now all of these agents could be
model-free which means they could have a
policy and or a value function but they
don't have an explicit model of the
environment
so note in particular that a value
function can of course also be
considered some model of some part of
the environment it's a model of the
cumulative expected rewards
but we're not calling them a model in
reinforcement learning parlance
typically so instead if you just have a
value function we tend to call this
model free
i'm saying that not because it's a great
definition or a great division between
agents but because it's a very common
one so if you read papers and they say
something about model-free reinforcement
planning this is what they mean there's
no explicit dynamics model
so conversely a model-based agent could
still ultimately oh sorry could still
optionally have an explicit policy and
or a value function but it does in any
case have a model some model based
agents only have a model and then have
to plan in order to extract their policy
other model based agents have a model
but in addition to that have an explicit
policy and for instance use the model to
sometimes just incrementally improve
value function or our policy
so now finally we're going to talk about
some sub problems of the rl problem
prediction
is about evaluating the future
so for instance learning a value
function you could call a prediction
problem and this is indeed often the
terminology that is used typically when
we say prediction we mean for a given
policy so you could think about
predicting the value of the uniformly
random policy for instance or of a
policy that always goes left or
something of the form
conversely control is about optimizing
the future finding the best policy
so it's good to note that this
terminology is used quite
frequently in papers so it's good to
have that in mind and often of course
these are quite related because if we
have good predictions then we can use
that to pick new policies
in fact the definition of the optimal
policy
pi star is the arc max of policies over
these value functions by definition the
value function defines which policies
are uh
the ranking on policies essentially your
preference on policies that doesn't mean
that you need to have these value
functions per se in order to learn
policies but it just shows shows how
strongly related to the problems of
prediction and control are
in addition there's an interesting
question that i encourage you to ponder
a little bit which is that
this is something that rich saturn often
says
that in one way or the other prediction
is maybe very good
form of knowledge
and in particular
if we could predict everything
it's unclear that we need additional
types of knowledge
and i want you to ponder that and think
about whether you agree with this or not
so if you could predict everything
is there anything else that we need
so feel free to pause the video and
think about that for a second
i'm going to give you one suggestion so
indeed if you can't predict everything
about the world this gives you a lot of
knowledge
it might not immediately tell you how to
do things so maybe it's sometimes useful
similar to these policies and value
functions sometimes it can be useful
especially if we're approximating so we
can't predict everything perfectly it
can be useful to separately store
predictions and separately scores
store policies or you could think of
these as them being skills in some sense
but indeed predictions are very
rich form of knowledge and many things
can be phrased as a predictive problem
even if they're not immediately clearly
a predictive problem uh
if you first think about them
and as i've referred to when i was
talking about models there's two
different parts to the reinforcement
voting uh
problem one is about learning
and this is the common setting which we
assume where the environment is
initially unknown and the agent
interacts with the environment and
someone has to learn
whether it's learning a value function a
policy or a model all of that could be
put under the header of learning
and then separately we could talk about
planning so planning is a common term in
artificial intelligence research
and planning is typically about when you
have a model so let's say the model of
the environment is just given to you
and then the agent somehow figures out
how best to optimize that problem
that would be planning so that means
you're using some compute to infer from
the statement of the problem from the
model is given what the best thing to be
to be done is
now
importantly the model doesn't have to be
given but could also be learned but then
it's good to keep in mind that the model
might be slightly inaccurate so if you
plan exhaustively in a learn model you
might find a certain policy but it's
unclear that this policy is actually
optimal in the true world because the
model might not be completely accurate
and indeed the planning might latch on
to certain inaccuracies in the model and
hence might find solutions that are
actually not that suitable for the real
world because for instance the model
might have a holy wall somewhere that is
not actually there and then the shortest
path might take the agent through that
hole which isn't actually there and the
policy might not be great that you get
from there
but we can think of planning more
generally as some sort of an internal
computation process so then learning
refers to
absorbing new experiences from this
interaction loop and planning is
something that sits internally inside
the agent's head it's a purely
computational process and indeed i
personally like to define planning as
any computational process that helps you
improve your policies or predictions or
other things inside the agent without
looking at new experience
learning is the part that looks at a new
experience that takes in your experience
and somehow condenses that and planning
is the part that does the additional
compute
that maybe turns in a model that you've
learned into a new policy
it's important also to know that all of
these components that we've talked about
so far can be represented as functions
we could have policies that map states
to actions or to probabilities over
actions value functions that map states
to to expected rewards or indeed also
two probabilities of these we have
models that map states to states or
state actions to states and we could
have rewards that map states to rewards
again or distributions over these and we
have a state of that function that takes
a state and an observation and
potentially an action and a reward and
maps it to a subsequent state
all of these are functions and that's
important because we have very good
tools to learn functions specifically
these days neural networks are very
popular very successful and the field of
researching how to train neural networks
is called deep learning
and indeed in reinforcement we can use
these deep learning techniques to learn
each of these functions and this has
been done with great success
it is good to take a little bit of care
when we do so because we do often
violate assumptions from say supervised
learning for instance the data coming at
us might be correlated
because for instance think of a robot
operating in a room it might spend some
substantial time in that room so if you
look at the data coming into the agent
it might be correlated over time and
then sometime later might go somewhere
else and this might be less correlated
but there might be in the near term
quite some strong correlations in the
data which are sometimes assumed not to
be there when you do supervised learning
in addition the problem is often assumed
to be stationary in supervised learning
in many supervised learning problems not
in all of course but in reinforcement
we're often interested in non-stationary
things think for instance of a value
function as i mentioned the value
function is a is typically
conditioned on a policy but if we're
doing control if we're trying to
optimize our policy the policy keeps on
changing that means that the relevant
value functions maybe also keep on
changing over time because maybe we want
to keep track of the value of the
current policy but if the policy keeps
on changing that means that the value
function also needs to change
so this is what i mean when i say we
often violate assumptions from
supervised learning that's not
necessarily a huge problem but it does
mean that whenever we want to use some
sort of a deep learning technique
sometimes they don't work out of the box
so deep learning is an important tool
for us when we want to apply
reinforcement learning to big problems
but deep reinforcement learning which is
basically a research field of the merger
of deep learning and reinforcement
burning or how to use deep learning in
reinforcement birding is a very rich and
active research field you can't just
plug in deep learning and then hope that
everything will immediately work that
works up to a point but there's lots of
reasons to be done exactly at that
intersection of deep learning and deep
reinforcement learning we'll talk much
more about that later in this course
okay
now that brings us to the final examples
so i talked about atari let's make it a
little bit more specific now what was
happening in the atari game that i
showed you so you can think of the
observations as the pixels as i
mentioned at that time point in time as
well
the output is the action which is the
joystick controls and the input is the
reward here on the slide it actually
shows the score but the actual reward
was the difference in score on every
time step
note that the rules of the game are
unknown and you learn directly from
interactive gameplay so you pick actions
on the joystick you see pixels and
scores and this
is a well-defined resource and printing
problem and we have algorithms that can
learn to deal well with this
as a different example here's a
schematic example a little bit more of
an illustrative example
and this is easy to easier to reason
through this is why we sometimes use
these much smaller examples and
oftentimes the conclusions still
transfer so the entire example is an
example of a rich messy
hard problem in some sense right and
this would be an example of a very small
scale illusive problem
and we do this because we can often
learn something from these smaller
problems that we can apply to these much
harder to understand difficult big
problems
so in this specific example which is
from the susan lombardo book
it's basically a great world without any
walls although there might be walls at
the at about at the edges essentially
but not any walls inside
the 5x5 grid
and there's a reward function which is
defined as -1 when bumping into a wall
zero on most steps
but in if you take any action from state
a the state that is labeled with a
you get a plus 10 reward and you
transition to a prime
so even if you press say up from set a
you still find yourself in a prime and
you get plus 10. similarly from state b
you would transition to state b prime
and you get plus five
now we can ask several different
questions about this setting and there
might be reasons why we might be
interested in these different
questions so a first question could be a
prediction question which is for
instance what is the value of the
uniform random policy that selects all
of the actions uniformly at random
and that's depicted here on the right
hand side in figure b
and what we see here is that this is
quite a complicated construct right i
wouldn't have been able to tell you just
immediately just by looking at the
problem what the value function is for
the optimal for sorry for the uniformly
random policy but we can use
reinforcement building algorithms which
we'll talk about in future lectures to
infer this
and to figure out what that value is
and it turns out just to look at this a
little bit more in detail that of course
the value of state a is quite high
because from this state you often get a
high you always get a high reward
but it's lower than 10 because the
rewards after this first reward of 10
are negative you see that the value of
state a prime is actually minus 1.3
sorry i didn't say but there's a
discount factor here as well 0.9
which means that the
this is why the the value of state a is
8.8
and the value of state a prime is 1.3
and the difference between them is not
quite 10 right um
but from from state b
you often get a minus one because you
often find yourself bumping to the to
the ball wall to bottom
or you don't get a minus one but then
you might get a minus one on the next
time so because you might have walked
left to the corner
and it's quite a complicated thing
because of the discount factor because
of the dynamics of the world but we can
see that state a is desirable state b is
somewhat desirable
states in the bottom left are quite
undesirable
but you might actually be more
interested in okay but what's the
optimal thing to be doing and that to me
is not immediately obvious right should
you be going to state a and then loop to
a prime
and get this plus 10 every time you
could but it takes you a couple of steps
in between each two times you do that
transition
you could also go to state b and go to b
prime and then you can get these
transitions more often
now it turns out we could also figure
out what the optimal value function is
for this problem and what the optimal
policy is
if you look at the optimal value they're
all positive now because you never have
to bump into a wall anymore because the
optimal policy doesn't bump into walls
so even the top sorry the bottom left
corner now has positive values
and in fact the lowest positive values
are in the bottom right corner now
because from there it takes you a long
time to get to the best possible state
you can and it turns out the best state
you can be in is state a
looping with these plus 10 rewards is
apparently more beneficial than looping
with these plus 5 rewards even though
the difference in
uh
distance
on these plus fives is smaller
so you can get more plus fives in a row
very quickly by going from b to b prime
after each like every time again but
going from a to a prime is apparently
more profitable in the long term and we
can see this in figure c here as well
where the optimal policy is depicted
we see that if you're in almost any
state what you should be doing is you
should be moving to state a this will
transition you all the way to the bottom
to a prime and from there you'll just
move straight up again
up to state a and repeat
conversely if you're in state b prime
if you just look at where b prime is in
this you would either go up or left it
doesn't actually matter which one
they're equally good
but if you go up you would then move
left so you wouldn't move into state b
instead you
would move left and then you move up or
left again in order to get state a
there's only one state that would move
into b
which is the top right corner
because from the top right going around
state b and then going all the way to a
would take so long that it's actually
more beneficial to jump into state b
which will transition you to b prime and
then from there we'll go to state a and
then loop indefinitely
so this is quite subtle i wouldn't have
been able to tell you just from looking
at the problem that this would be the
optimal policy but fortunately we have
learning and planning algorithms that
can sort that out for us and they can
find this optimal solution without us
having to find it
so popping up in this course we will
discuss how to learn by interaction we
didn't really discuss it in this lecture
in this lecture we just talked about the
concepts and the terminology and things
like that but we haven't really given
you algorithms yet we will do that in
the subsequent lectures
and the focus will be on understanding
the core principles and learning
algorithms so it's less about what the
current state of the artist will touch
upon that a little bit for sure but it's
less about specific algorithms that
people happen to use right now and then
go all the way to the depth of those
we will do that for some algorithms but
it's much more important to understand
the core principles and learning
algorithms because the algorithms that
are currently safer they will change
next year there will be new algorithms
and if you understand the core
principles
then you can understand these new
algorithms and maybe you could even
invent your own algorithms
topics include exploration in the next
lecture
in something called bandits which is
basically one step
mark of decision processes
we will talk about more about what
marketing decision processes actually
are like how are they mathematically
defined and what can we say about them
and we will talk about how to plan in
those with dynamic programming this will
be the lectures after the next lecture
by this user will be given by diana
and then we will use that to
then go into model-free prediction and
control algorithms you may have heard of
an algorithm called q-learning
or i mentioned earlier in this lecture
an algorithm called dqn dqm is short for
deep q network
q as i mentioned is often used to refer
to state action values
q learning is an algorithm that can
learn state action values and then the
dqn algorithm is an algorithm that uses
q-learning in combination with deep
neural networks to learn these entire
games
this falls on the model 3 prediction and
control because no explicit model of the
environment is learned in that algorithm
we will also talk about policy gradient
methods we in fact already touch upon
them in the next lecture but we'll talk
about them more later and these are
methods that can use be used to learn
policies directly without necessarily
using a value function but we also
discuss actor critic algorithms in which
you have both an explicit policy network
or function and you have an explicit
value function
and this brings us also to deep
reinforcement training because as i
mentioned these functions are often
represented these days with deep neural
networks that's not the only choice they
could also be linear or it could be
something else
but
it's a popular
choice for a reason and it works really
well and we'll discuss that at some
length later in this course
and also we will talk about how to
integrate learning and planning i talked
a little bit about planning being an
internal computation process and then
learning meaning the process that takes
a new experience and learns from that
and of course we could have both of
those happening at the same time in an
agent and then we want them to play
nicely together
and there will be much more there will
be other topics that we'll touch upon
when we go through all of this
okay
now finally i want to show you one final
example of a reinforcement writing
problem
again what we'll see here is a little
bit more of a complicated example
so what we'll see is a system which was
learned to
control the body so you can see the body
already here on the still
i'll press play in a moment and what
will happen is is that there's an
algorithm that controls the uh basically
the forces of these uh body parts so
this agent specifically it can run right
and it had to learn itself how to move
its limbs in such a way as to produce
forward motion the reward was a very
simple one
the reward was just go in that one
direction
and you'll get plus one or you get
positive reward
basically proportional to how fast you
go in that direction so it really wants
to go really fast in one direction it
was not told how to do that so it
doesn't at first when it starts swelling
it doesn't know how to control its limbs
it just knows that it
that it's
it perceives the world in some sense by
by sensors which i won't go into that
much depth it's too not too important
here but the point is it doesn't know
how to move its limbs it has to figure
that out by itself and it just notices
that when it moves in certain ways it
gets more rewarding in other ways
doing that
you get the following behavior
with simplified vision as it says on the
slide and proprioception which means it
can it can feel essentially where its
own limbs are in some sense
and then it can traverse through this
very complicated uh domain and it can
learn how to jump over things and how to
maybe even climb in some sense
just because it wants to go to the right
not everything is easy but it does
manage to get there
now interestingly
by using this setting by just having a
simple reward you can traverse different
types of domains you can learn to
terrain sorry you can learn to traverse
different types of terrains and do this
in very non-trivial ways
it would be very hard to specify a
policy by hand that does this and in
fact because we have a learning system
it's not just that we don't have to
specify a thing by hand but we can also
apply the exact same learning system to
different body types
so this was learned with the exact same
system
that was used for this other thing and
you can use this in two dimensions or
you can use it in three dimensions
and in each of these cases the agent can
learn
by interaction how to actually scale
these obstacles
so the reward is particularly simple we
didn't have to think about how to move
the limbs in order to do that we can
just have the learning system come up
with that and that's the important point
here
and you can apply some more difficult uh
terrains you can apply this to different
body types you can get quite non-trivial
behavior in doing so
okay so that brings us to the end of
this lecture
thank you for paying attention
and
we'll see you in the next lecture which
will be on the topic of expiration